[Music]
hello reject nation it's time to sweep
the leg ain't that right what Johnny off
oh yeah of course
what you just have to interrupt you just
have to interrupt I was gonna say Johnny
like sweep the leg Johnny like the
Karate Kid
Angie Turing requested this video Ralph
Macchio just apparently not in the way
that's technically I think this is the
Karate Kid continues first ever footage
of Cobra Kai oh man ever like even
before them yeah documentaries all right
let's let's check this out I forgot who
are the people behind this I came here
for the show or like a special little
movie it's James man yeah man shouldn't
you cross them over
it meets Jaden Smith we had a very
similar story did you have a mentor too
I was like an old taught you about you
know pages stumble into your life as
you're getting bullied
[Music]
you're not trying to be merciful here
mercy is for the weak you may not lose
but none of that matters unless you have
balance
[Music]
Oh camera cut right after no YouTube
radnyx original series maybe people will
subscribe now this is the property
they've been needing you know what this
makes me think of something that I think
that no one's thought of yet
eighties nostalgia what yeah do you mean
the 80s are back in I feel like 80s
nostalgia is really in right I don't
know dude 70s man yeah I know
retro means is the seven I know but I
think right now I feel like there's an
80s wave approaching are you mean to
tell me that all the kids who were
children in the 80s who have now come of
age and are making all these movies are
revitalizing the stuff that they grew up
on is that what you're trying to tell me
that could be a possibility I don't know
dude I'd have to see science and numbers
and proof you know what I love about
this trailer is how serious in tone it
is but it's just not gonna be that at
all it's gonna be a comedy it has to be
it has to be a comedy right seriously
the difference I think you could be a
hundred percent sir I feel like you got
to do like that 80's badassness about it
yeah but have a have a sense of humor
about it have a tongue-in-cheek about it
because they're getting Johnny Lawrence
the dude who he originally fought in the
tournament and he's revitalizing an all
valley karate
Hachiko who is returning again and
they're continuing the same competition
they have with every kids from so many
decades ago and karate and Taekwondo and
all that those martial arts styles are
just not in right now
yeah so this has to be a little bit of a
joke that's I like this serious stuff
because they're much older now I was
expecting some humor in here because
then they're doing like kicks and stuff
I'm like that looks cool the kicks
through some pretty bad ass kicks so
thank you you got to have some cool like
karate action have an 80s sense of humor
about itself because you can't take
itself too seriously that wouldn't that
would it be a good thing I think no I
feel like you have to poke fun at what's
dated you know embrace the themes that
are relevant to now cuz there is I don't
know
I get the strike first strike hard no
mercy I get where like exploring that
theme might be a good idea today
now that we're all riled up and agitated
is not Creed yeah one and then shot at
the end where they like step in and face
each other it was kind of funky like
Ralph Macchio just looks like a young
person to me although you gotta admit
it's pretty cool that they got Johnny
and Danny back something fun and cool
about it I remember wax on and wax off
and smooth like Johnny have been the
biggest quotes from The Karate Kid and
even a few years ago I finally saw that
music video of a sweep the leg Johnny
that like hardcore rock and roll song
yeah yeah which I hope they have one for
this job having them back does make it a
little bit more enticing
I don't know how drawn people are to
YouTube bread though is anyone really
watch YouTube red shows I mean they've
had certain events and things that seem
like they grabbed eyeballs but I don't
hear a lot of people talk about you know
anything special going on YouTube red
they need is a Marvel show something I'm
sure that would help YouTube read out a
lot who's creating it though Oh Kumar's
an American Reunion and a Hayden
Schlossberg co-wrote all those with him
as well yeah this is gotta be a comedy I
don't even think drama D is the right
word this has to be a comedy Danny and
Johnny don't have careers now they're
known for Karate Kid you know they have
to just be able to in case of like viral
thing they were a sketch that came out
about Ralph Macchio being too nice or
whatever I think they were in How I Met
Your Mother they're known for who they
are personality isn't they're not known
for their talent is actors anymore or
something like that you know but hey
they both look good they look older
which is expected sometime works thanks
for requesting this Angie Terpening my
big handsome man that you are
Andrew I don't even going through a
rough patch right now it's totally
understandable even beautiful men go
through rough times even the beautiful
ones like people like John sometimes I
have a rough day despite how beautiful
he is a lot of rough day me because I'm
not as good-looking as John I naturally
wake up in a bad mood I naturally go to
sleep depressed I can identify with all
the feelings that are going through
Andrew just know this despite how sad
you get despite how depressed times may
be I know you're trying to reinvent your
life and find yourself and get yourself
ready to go out there and find the woman
of your dreams and fall in love just
know this no matter how hard life gets
you are still really good looking true
that man at the end of the day see
that's all that matters you can sing you
have medical capabilities all that even
yeah that's like all whatever but you
yeah look the fact that you're
good-looking that's what that's what
values are like yeah cuz even when
you're depressed and you don't get the
woman of your dreams you can still
rebound yeah yeah not me but he can huh
and you can yeah you can you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and check
on our patreon become a patron eject
today and maybe just maybe we'll
consider getting a YouTube read account
so we could watch the first episode yeah
yeah entice us ytr redtube Red Dead
Revolver